I'm doing a PhD in neuroscience under
the Department of Medicine and my main
focus of the investigation of the visual
aspects of psychedelics for the
privilege to be the other side to
experience kind of the subject size of
things an enemy I was injected with LSD
75 micrograms of LSD I didn't really
know what I was to expect being in the
scanner is very it's a very different
situation the experience was actually
nice and then after that they kind of
saw that I'm okay
there's no drug effect and after that I
went to the park an afterglow of the
drugs of it in the park
so in addiction and also in depression
sometimes the patients are quite locked
in certain patterns of thought and maybe
this allows them in the moment of the
therapy session to be more flexible and
kind of investigated different parts of
their personality or your mind and
through that and kind of learn new
things about himself from the therapy
session
[Music]